let's talk about the serious situation
the Comey interview and what we did not
see last night senior political analyst
Brit Hume joins us
good evening Brett first your thoughts
on the Comey rollout and that interview
with George Stephanopoulos well it seems
to me Bret that Comey comes across as a
man who at least in his own eyes tried
very hard to do the right thing and
failed I mean he wouldn't say that he
failed but you look at the mistakes he
made over time deciding the Hillary
Clinton investigation for one I think he
very are quite likely reads the wrong
decision about whether she should be
prosecuted his argument flies in the
face of the statute governing the
handling of classified information then
he proceeded to announce that usurping
the role a decision and the role of the
Attorney General then he proceeded to
come out and and say that the
investigation had been reopened which he
should not have done in my view and said
so I said so at the time and then of
course that led him when the
investigation had been finished again to
come out later on and say all that all
of which had the effectively some effect
on the election campaign something Comey
said that it made him sick to his
stomach to think that he might be doing
but he did it and he and he comes across
to me as almost as a sad figure and and
this and these attacks that verbal
attacks on the man who fired him are
unseemly I would say that the
president's responses are equally sowed
maybe even more so but these all add up
to kind of a catalogue of mistakes by
Comey which are in no way I think he
relieved with no way of the
responsibility for them by these
interviews or this book you know Brit
the ABC interview
it appeared heavily edited and we know
that it was some five hours of interview
between George Stephanopoulos and James
Comey some of it on the edit room floor
one part from the transcript Comey says
we had the problem that President Obama
had twice publicly basically said
there's no there there in an interview
with on Fox and an interview on 60
minutes I think both times he said that
so that's his Justice Department
Stephanopoulos says did that surprise
you call me it really did surprise me
he's a very smart man and a lawyer so it
surprised me he shouldn't have done it
it was inappropriate that did
make it into the interview now and you
would think that an interview is so
heavily laced with his attacks on
President Trump which are undoubtedly
newsworthy and certainly should have
been included that the fact that he was
critical of President Obama on a matter
related to the Hillary Clinton
investigation would have made it into
the interview I'm surprised it didn't it
should have what about the serious
situation you had the US ambassador to
the United Nations yesterday on a Sunday
show saying that sanctions were coming
as soon as today from the Treasury
secretary on Russia and then today the
White House kind of walking that back
saying they're considering what to do in
the wake of all of this to have that
kind of back-and-forth today while it's
embarrassing in light of what I think
has been widely regarded as a successful
mission in Syria and to have this
apparent contradiction I don't know
whether it's a contradiction in terms of
the policy itself the toward Russia on
sanctions or whether it's it's simply a
matter of timing but I guess we'll soon
see as for the as for the mission itself
we keep hearing a breath from critics of
it that what we really need here is a
broader Syria policy and that what would
and and the bombing runs are no
substitute for that I I'd be inclined to
disagree with that in the sense Brett
which is this I think the president's
ambitions and intentions in Syria are
really quite limited I think he wants to
obviously to finish the job against Isis
and get our forces out of there once
that's done and I think he wants to
deter the further use of chemical
weapons that he's not trying to side in
a civil war against Assad particularly
but he is saying these weapons cross a
line a line that was once drawn by his
predecessor who did nothing when it was
crossed so I think that's basically
where we are two things defeat Isis and
deter the use of chemical weapons and
that's about it not and that may not be
the right policy but that's what it is
and it is an effective policy Brett as
always thank you you've got